une victoire stratégique pour l'Ukraine
il y a encore quelques heures cette
ville était le symbole de l'occupation
russe depuis le début de la guerre
samedi les militaires ukrainiens ont
annoncé avoir encerclé plusieurs
milliers de soldats russes une défaite
pour l'armée russe qui rassure les pays
de l'OTAN dans leur soutien à l'Ukraine
nos alliés intensifient leur soutien à
l'Ukraine et c'est la meilleure façon de
s'assurer que l'Ukraine puisse reprendre
ses territoires occupés au cours de
cette semaine nous avons vu qu'ils ont
pu reprendre une ville cela démontre que
les Ukrainiens progressent ils sont
capables de repousser les forces russes
grâce à leur courage leur bravoure leurs
compétences mais bien sûr aussi grâce
aux armes fournies par les États-Unis et
d'autres alliés
si l'armée russe n'a fait aucun
commentaire sur l'iman après avoir
annoncé samedi qu'elle retirait ses
forces vers des positions plus
favorables dimanche la télévision d'État
a diffusé des images des troupes russes
des forces séparatistes ukrainiennes se
prépareront à maintenir la ligne
défensive dans la région de Liman les
forces armées ressortent détruit
plusieurs dépôts d'artillerie et de
missiles dans des régions ukrainiennes
cette dépôt de missile d'armement
d'artillerie et de munitions ont été
détruits dans les régions ukrainiennes
de quartier Nicolas poridia et Donetsk
un radar de guidage de S300 et de
système de missiles de défense aérien
ont également été détruits dans la
région de Carson
[Musique]
lors d'un échange téléphonique ce
dimanche Emmanuel Macron a réaffirmé
auprès de volody mers elenski la
détermination de la France a été
l'Ukraine à retrouver sa pleine
souveraineté son intégrité territoriale
et à travailler avec ses partenaires
européens à de nouvelles sanctions